nous on défend le bilan de prison de la
république notre objectif c'est pouvoir
parler aussi aux gènes en reprenant
leurs codes
entre la campagne de 2017 est
aujourd'hui et défaites nous ont fait du
mal beaucoup ont cru qu'on allait finir
par tomber qu'on allait sombrer mais
aujourd'hui on voit énormément de
militants qui reviennent et des nouveaux
en fait des très jeunes
[Musique]
ces marchés
on la priorité c'est vraiment l'urgence
climatique et problème c'est que
beaucoup partie en fait et c'est de
mettre du vert sur le papier mais en
réalité il ya peu de choses qui sont
faites
c'est un spot où il ya vraiment beaucoup
de passage avec des voitures donc ça
permet vraiment de donner de la
visibilité à nos affiches de toute façon
elles seront retirées très rapidement
mais là au moins il ya des passages
hockey
bonjour madame regarder ensemble
national prôné le 22 pendant français
leur pays bonjour monsieur je vais vous
en donner aussi vous êtes la libération
leur nom s'est pas émoussée mieux
français marine le pen c'est mieux
séparer mais maintenant c'est pas pareil
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur jean luc mélenchon pour
les élections présidentielles bonjour
jean luc mélenchon pour les élections
présidentielles
[Musique]
le seul crédible bonjour madame aux
élections présidentielles le programme
des communistes vous intéresse bonjour
madame tenez vous tournez vous
connaissez le candidat ou pas on fait
c'est contente de parler aussi un petit
peu aux jeunes de leur dire voilà en
fait un petit coin jeu tu votes pas
c'est pas ça qui compte
ça c'est le programme d'algos pour la
présidentielle je sais pas si vous êtes
un peu sensibilisé des politiques
oui oui je suis pas convaincu
bonjour madame vous avez déjà le bon
track voilà en espérant que les
propositions vous
[Musique]
en science politique on va on va appeler
accident biographique
ddd événement dans la vie personnelle
alors ça peut être des événements
traumatiques ça peut être des événements
familiaux des événements professionnels
qui vont en fait conduire à réouvrir en
fait des trajectoires a rencontré des
citoyens et qui va amener à basculer
dans quelque chose qui n'était pas prévu
au départ donc je pense effectivement
que ce côté un peu plus incertain des
trajectoires sociales permet à des gens
qui n'avaient pas forcément des
prédispositions à s'engager à le faire
[Musique]
c'est vrai que bon c'est pas évident
avec avec la fac et dans 93 mon
appartement qui est dans 95 je fais un
peu le le taux de l'is france j'irai
mais il n'y a pas le choix
l'oriental
j'ai payé mon loyer je paye mes courses
toutes les charges que j'ai j'aide aussi
un peu mes parents parfois en leur
faisant quelques courses c'est tout
simplement de faire le nécessaire même
si c'est un job étudiant et voilà c'est
tout c'est surtout pas face aux
samouraïs je m'installe à 60 mauriac à
tétouan à chaque fois que je faisais des
vies d'appartements comme ce soir ont
refusé il ya une réticence envers les
étudiants et j'ai réussi à trouver à une
semaine de la rentrée je me rappelle que
le monsieur m'a appelé en me disant que
oui mais on en vient de voir de vos
dossiers on peut vous prendre un
logement pour vous quinze mètres carrés
mais par contre c'est 700 700 euros pour
un pour un étudiant
c'est c'est super dur ses supérieurs
je me suis dit il faut que jadis il faut
que j'essaie de changer les choses à mon
échelle à ma petite échelle même si
voilà je sais jamais si on sait jamais
ce qui peut se passer on sait jamais ce
que la vie nous réserve mais au moins
d'essayer d'essayer de faire changer ces
choses là je suis intégré le parti
socialiste
[Musique]
à 17 ans j'ai vécu une rupture familiale
comme beaucoup de français et je laime
réfugie chez des amis chez ma copine
c'est vrai que malheureusement ça s'est
terminé puis donc en partant je partis
avec deux cartons et malheureusement
j'avais absolument aucun endroit où
dormir et donc j'ai choisi cet endroit
parce qu'il était proche de là où je vis
et puis je connaissais déjà un petit peu
puisque c'est vrai que j'ai pratiqué la
pêche alors j'ai dormi ici deux nuits et
donc j'ai passé trois jours ce qui
paraît peu mais je vous garantis que ça
fait une éternité quand vous les vivez
ce sont des choses qui arrivent à
beaucoup de français
lorsque vous arrivez dans la rue la
première des réactions c'est la honte
je me rappelle d'une dame qui étaient
assez âgés qui est passé qui s'est
arrêté pour me regarder et j'ai jamais
eu aussi honte de ma vie qu'on croit en
son regard
j'ai cumulé un emploi de nuit avec mes
études que j'ai dû finalement abandonnée
puis grâce à cela j'ai eu un cdi + 1
garante qui m'ont permis de louer une
chambre de 9 m² ici à saint germain en
laye que je paye 500 euros par mois avec
un revenu de taper le mur
j'ai souhaité que l'état puisse un
minimum de prendre en charge puisque je
travaillais alors je payer des
cotisations et tout le monde m'expliquer
mais va voir la cave va voir la mision
la mission locale sont des choses qui
arrivent partout sur le territoire
national est donc bien évidemment
beaucoup de jeunes sont dans ces
situations et l'état t'aidera et j'avais
un de mes collègues fraîchement arrivé
d'erythrée qui lui avait en appartement
un t3 dans les environs à chatou et qui
désireux de faire venir sa famille avait
sollicité l'état pour avoir quelque
chose de plus grand malheureusement moi
je l'avais droit à rien et j'ai reçu
cette phrase fait toujours résonance
dans mon coeur
monsieur rivière vous êtes français vous
avez de la famille si quelqu'un pourra
peut-être vous héberger et bien moi
l'état ne m'a pas aidé comme il n'y est
plus malheureusement beaucoup de ces
enfants
j'ai tout simplement pris une carte au
rassemblement national parce que c'était
le party qui défendez les valeurs
traditionnelles qui défendrait la
famille la patrie
l'identité française
tous ses credo qui sont très chers à mon
coeur et je ne m'en suis jamais caché
pour moi c'est une fierté d'être
patriote il faut être fier d'être
français fier de le dire
[Musique]
alors à mon père il travaille dans le
bâtiment donc dans des dans des
chantiers comme ça c'est un métier
vraiment qui est dur et en plus ils
travailler tout seul et était auto
entrepreneur est en fait du coup un jour
mon papa il fait diagnostiquer un cancer
un cancer des poumons
comme il était tout seul quand il valait
l'hôpital ballet chantier n'avançait pas
au bout d'un moment on était tellement
endetté et les chantiers il prenait
tellement de retard qu'ils étaient
obligés d'engager des gens pour
travailler à sa place sauf que du coup
en fait c'est une traque était à perte
et c'est quand même incroyable que de se
dire que quand tu es malade en plus de
sa maladie était la source du stress de
comment je vais faire pour nous
remercier comment je vais faire pour
pouvoir continuer de payer mon loyer du
coup tu joues tu peux pas tu peux pas
lutter c'est pas possible de lutter
contre ça
[Musique]
finalement il n'a pas pu s'en sortir il
est décédé quand j'avais 14 ans en 2014
donc ça a été très dur pour moi et c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles je
me suis engagé avec jean luc mélenchon
parce que les gens ne devraient pas
avoir à vivre ça tu peux pas devoir
travailler quand tu es malade c'est pas
normal que tu doivent continuer à
traquer dans les chantres et parce que
tu es pauvre tout sa racine en
définitive dans la question sociale et
dans la dénonciation de la cupidité d'un
système le système capitaliste qui
domine d'autres sociétés
c'est pas comme ça que la ville devrait
marcher et je me suis engagé avec jean
luc mélenchon parce que lui déjà il
proposera une aide médicale et un suivi
qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus que
ce qui est actuellement inscrits et
sociales et mon propose la hausse du
smic à 1400 euros net parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas vivre
dignement avec un smic donc jean luc
mélenchon c'est la réduction de travail
et c'est la retraite à 60 ans et ça
devrait être comme ça pour tous tous les
gens
[Musique]
j'allais prendre le bus donc je prenais
ce chemin tous les matins et du coup il
y avait un homme ont été très tôt du
coup une bête 7 heures du matin il va un
homme derrière entre les barrières
derrière moi
il était nu alcoolisées et qui a tenté
de l'agresser sexuellement
donc il a essayé de m'attraper
je me suis débattue fin j'ai crié je me
suis débattue et je les pousse et j'ai
couru jusqu'à l'arrêt de bus
j'aimais cluzet harcèlement de rue en
fait tout le monde aussi dans une
conversation entre au fait c'est très
très rare qu'une ça ne sera jamais
arrivé c'est pour ça que méditer qu'on
essaie d'expliquer justement et ces
femmes que oui il ya quelque chose à
faire et que ça doit pas rester impuni
ce n'est pas juste quelque chose qui
arrive et un autre dans la rue et que
c'est pas grave parce que même si on ne
ressent pas traumatisés comme moi par
exemple bas en fait c'est quand même
important de dire et de faire nous les
procédures qui pourraient
la honte que subissent ces femmes une
honte ils légitimes parce qu'elles sont
déjà victimes
7 août doit devenir celle de ses auteurs
de violence et c'est surtout une honte
civiques et politiques une route
nationale de leurs abus une femme meurt
tous les trois jours en france je vous
prie d'observer une minute de silence en
hommage à ces femmes battues violées
moi quand j'ai entendu ce discours j'ai
juste eu envie de bad de concrétiser mon
engagement
j'étais du coup déjà intéressé par
évidemment les hits et emmanuel macron
mais pour la première fois un président
de la république qui proclame que du
coup l'égalité femmes-hommes c'est la
grande cause du quinquennat bas rhin
s'était jamais arrivé alors que passait
un sujet qu'on avait juste sous le nez
et que le fait de dire que c'est c'est
la pentecôte du quinquennat c'est
rassurant et puis ça se voit qu'il ya
une volonté d'agir et finalement je me
suis pas trompé parce que au final
quelques mois après ça il y avait le
grenelle des violences conjugales il y
avait toutes les mesures qui ont été
mises en place donc c'est il n'a tenu sa
promesse
[Musique]
si je me suis orienté vers la droite qui
à l'époque c'était l'ump c'est parce
qu'elles portaient des sujets qui me
parlait qui me parlait le plus moi je
viens d'un milieu qui n'est pas
forcément des plus favorisés mon père et
retraités anciens militaires ma mère et
comment les cuisinières et il ya
toujours eu cette valeur du travail à la
maison et c'est dans la droite que je
retrouvais ses valeurs la gauche elle
peut faire la promotion commande un
biberonnage éternelle si je puis dire
c'est à dire que à coups d'allocations à
coup de subventions on va dire on va
noyer le poisson sauf que s'accomplir
par soi-même et accomplir des choses
personnelles et professionnelles il ya
rien de plus gratifiant
c'est ça aussi qui fait grandir
ici il ya quelques années c'était
vraiment le haut lieu des commandes et
contestation sociale et anti fasciste
c'est là où il y avait les groupes
principaux qui s'énerve et qui
s'activait si je puis dire et notamment
en s'introduisant dans les commandants
les dans les bâtiments les saccageant et
en interrompant les cours
ce qu'ils voulaient ni plus ni moins
c'était reproduire la protestation
sociale qu'il y avait en ville au sein
même de la faculté donc notamment lors
de la loi travail la loi sur la
sélection à l'université également tous
ces contestations là ont été transposées
de la rue à l'université
[Musique]
avec quelques étudiants on a été
fichiers directement par par les
bloqueurs tout simplement parce que nous
on s'opposer à ces méthodes là on a
affiché nos comptes twitter et nos
portraits sur la bibliothèque
universitaire on nous pointer du doigt
certains ont été comment jeter au sol
alors qu'ils étaient blessés ça a été
des mois et des mois de pressions
qu'elle n'a pas fallu céder oui je me
souviens même d'une fois où il y avait
une assemblée générale où je me suis je
me suis pointé tout seul comme un
gaillard si je puis dire est qu'il ya eu
un vote pour que je parte mais je leur
ai expliqué chez les gars vous pouvez
voter autant que vous voulez moi je
partirai pas je suis là pour écouter et
savoir ce que vous allez dire hélas deux
personnes sont venues me voir en
mais carton assez rapidement qu'ils
étaient pour le coup là deux personnes à
ses sens et qui m'ont dit carl pour ton
bien il faut que tu t'en ailles
[Musique]
lorsque j'étais petit mes parents
étaient déjà très engagé en tout cas et
son sont initiées en fait dès que le
gouvernement a proposé les poubelles
jaunes les poubelles du tri sélectif ils
ont commencé à le faire et nous
apprendre à le faire et on va dire que
c'était mes premiers pas on va dire dans
le milieu de l'écologie et puis aussi
beaucoup sensibilisé à la cause animale
et par la suite du coup avec l'actualité
et à travers le lycée j'ai commencé à me
pencher un peu plus sur des sujets
précis et des actions concrètes
[Musique]
j'écris et du coup les jeunes pour le
climat de vitrolles pour essayer
justement de diffuser le plus largement
possible la prise d'initiative sur des
gestes écocitoyens vraiment un public
très varié alors c'est vrai la jeunesse
peut être en priorité parce que je pense
que c'est là où il ya le plus d'efforts
à faire puisque ça va être vraiment
notre futur en fait qui est vraiment en
jeu et je veux prouver en fait aux
autres enfin en tout cas leur montrer
que c'est pas bien compliqué et que au
final on en récolte
on en récolte les fruits quoi
son
le site sur lequel j'aime bien aller
c'est le site réseau tee donc c'est
vraiment le site sur lequel on va
retrouver toutes les offres d'emploi
liées à l'environnement l'écologie et la
biodiversité
et c'est vrai que celui qui m'intéresse
le plus à mettre l'éducation
l'environnement et les services
écologiques et à la biodiversité par
exemple management environnemental
recherchez un environnement risque de
pollution sol sous sol environnements
systèmes d'information tourisme durable
transport durable éco mobilité urbanisme
et cadre de vie
j'ai passé un bac scientifique et moi ce
que j'aimais vraiment c'était la
biodiversité sauvage et locales de
préférence donc restez donc sur une fois
deux françaises et ça ça m'a paru une
évidence
début de début de mes années fac
il faut vraiment être déjà passionnés
mais aussi extrêmement motivés et prêts
à s'impliquer
dans la vie de tous les jours dans ce
domaine là
or cet endroit il est très important
parce que c'est un lieu stratégique où
justement la biodiversité et bien y
trouver un point repères pour nicher
mais aussi présente une halte migratoire
malheureusement des
en danger du moins sensible par les
différents facteurs polluants qui sont
autour on savait très bien de la
nuisance sonore
lumineuse ou encore là les perturbations
à cause de l'aéroport qui est juste à
côté ou encore la pollution de l'air
avec les usines de berre qui sont en
face
on retrouve deux gros déchet donc de
gros encombrants ici c'est pas normal
que ça que ça puisse passer c'est
dommage parce que d'un côté on va mettre
des panneaux pour
expliquer la sensibilité du milieu mais
d'un autre côté il ya des espaces donc
des bâtiments qui vont qui sont
construits très récemment avec une
hausse de la fréquentation douce et très
contradictoires on sent qu'il ya
peut-être une volonté du gouvernement
mais en réalité on ne va pas jusqu'au
bout du projet rien ne garantit la
protection du milieu et ça c'est dommage
[Musique]
au début je suis petit j'ai toujours
voulu être marin mon père est marin mon
grand père était marin c'est toujours un
rêve que j'ai eu c'est un boulot qui est
quand même assez précaire parce que tu
sais pas en fait quand tu pars tu sais
pas quand tu reviens je sais pas
vraiment à quel point tu vas être payés
parce que souvent tu es payé à la part
en plus donc à la pêche donc ouais c'est
un métier assez précaire mais derrière
il les salaires ils sont généralement un
peu plus élevé que la moyenne en raison
aussi des conditions de travail est
beaucoup plus difficile
j'ai commencé vraiment un mauvais certes
plus personnellement en 2017
après le second tour macron le pen ou en
fait là j'ai commencé à sentir le danger
du fascisme avec le pen et du coup me
suis un peu intéressé est ce que c'est l
antifascisme et tout et c'est là que
j'ai découvert le communisme vraiment
comme mode de société et aussi comme
manière de faire face au fascisme
et suite à ça un jour un soir en
rentrant chez moi il y avait sur un
arrêt de bus cole est natif de l'ajc qui
recouvrait une affiche de marine le pen
et là je me suis dit mais en fait ces
gens là qui me faut tout le monde sait
tous on se le dit que le système il est
pourri jusqu'à la moelle que il sera
très très dur à améliorer et en fait
c'est pour ça que moi quand on quand
j'ai rencontré les communistes aussi et
que j'ai vu là leur véritable volonté
d'arriver un fondement de société
profond mais monsieur dit mais en fait
oui c'est ça depuis le début c'est ça
qui marche quoi c'est vraiment il faut
une perspective révolutionnaire
vivre des jours heureux
vive la république
vive la
toutes leurs formes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout à l'heure j'ai oublié de féliciter
quelqu'un est bien remercier quelqu'un
qui est venu qui vient du nord mathilde
le conte du mouvement générations
zemmour qu'on peut aplatir
j'ai grandi dans une famille d'une
classe moyenne
une famille très soudée très aimante
très ouvert au monde très cultivé ils
nous ont toujours permis d'avoir accès à
de l'information et c'est vraiment ça
qui a commencé à susciter chez moi un
intérêt pour la politique concernant mon
engagement politique ce qu'il ya
vraiment créer le déclic c'est les
élections présidentielles de 2017 et
lorsque les débats aux présidentielles
ont commencé je me suis rendu compte de
l'offre politique qui nous était proposé
et j'ai été extrêmement déçu c'est là où
je me suis rendu compte que autour de
moi beaucoup de jeunes ne s'intéressait
plus à la politique et c'était
inévitable il fallait absolument que je
participe et que je change les choses
c'est un peu prétentieux de dire ça mais
je voulais simplement agir et servir à
quelque chose pour mon pays donc j'ai
rejoint les républicains
c'était assez naturel de rejoindre les
républicains puisque encore une fois mon
père avait voté sarkozy et j'avais une
image très positive du parti des
républicains c'était pour moi le parti
de droite par excellence c'était un
parti de valeur un parti de convictions
et valeurs
éternelles des femmes
c'était une droite que je considérais
forte qui me correspondait tout à fait
aujourd'hui lorsque je vois la
candidature de valérie pécresse et
qu'elle a traité ses militants à l'air
jeunes qui commençaient à se radicaliser
je me suis dit que les républicains ne
correspondait plus du tout parce que
leurs programmes n'étaient plus en
adéquation avec moi et parce que la
candidate qu'il avait choisi ne
représentait pas pour moi la droite
forte qui étaient les républicains eric
zemmour est donc arrivé à ce moment là
dans ma vie
je le suivais déjà beaucoup dans ses
interventions sur ces news c'était
quelqu'un que je trouve extrêmement
intelligent et cultivé et j'étais de
plus en plus fasciné par le personnage
c'était comme quelque chose qu'on avait
toujours attendus un homme politique
servi sur un plateau d'argent pour la
droite
le prix à payer c'est c'est du temps
l'activité politique l'activité
militante ça se fait pas de manière
intermittente ça se fait plus de sur un
temps long
ça se fait il compris le soir et surtout
le soir et surtout en fête le week-end
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il ya une
radicalité plus forte chez des jeunes
parce qu'ils veulent des résultats on va
vouloir on va sur investir un
investissement militants partisans et
c'est vrai que le fait de désigner un
ennemi zemmour marine le pen mac ronde
mélenchon peu de temps dans des choses
et puis aussi le contexte des médias des
médias des réseaux sociaux ou la
violence l'anathème linge heures
deviennent un véritable mode de
communication
[Musique]
waouh
consommation en berne sous terre
et oui ce n est pas la paye ma néou est
donc chassé l'humanitaire ils font
souvent enfin à chaque édition il ya
l'homme où la femme du jour
une fois j'ai eu l'homme du jour gaspard
fontaine un décrocheur au coeur bien
accroché il n'a que 19 ans mais la force
son engagement on fait déjà un militant
aguerri c'est un soumi étudiant en droit
comparé ces 23 mars devant le tribunal
d'amiens pour répondre du vol du
portrait de manet mâcon le procureur a
requis 500 euros d'amendé contre lui le
verdict sera rendu le 20 avril
il s'est trouvé que par un concours de
circonstances c'est moi qui me suis
retrouvé à décrocher ce portrait et du
couple en mars 2020 j'étais à la mairie
d'amiens et gt on sent la mairie j'avais
pris le portrait et j'étais parti avec
enfin je les retirer du conseil pour
laisser un vide à la place et ce terrain
vide à l'image des politiques qu'ils
étaient menés par macron et par son
gouvernement en termes de justice
sociale et de justice climatique suite à
ça j'ai été poursuivi on va auditionner
en garde à vue
tu fais laisser ma peau si j'étais au
magasin j'arrive et je suis en train de
laver au magasin mais c'est vrai qu'au
bas quand on vous appelle vous dit que
votre fils en garde à vue quel que soit
l'âge eu forcément ça pourtant que mr un
peu gros sur la patate qu il n'aurait
pas de répercussions aussi sur ta vie
plus tard quoi c'est surtout par rapport
à ça je me dis je passe non plus plus
tard et malgré un casier judiciaire
pardon par rapport à ces mots du coup
c'est bon j'en ai plus on peut on peut
péter je n'ai pas tué je suis rassuré
mais honnêtement je suis rassuré alors
ça c'est à mon procès c'était jean luc
mélenchon qui étaient venus soutenir y
avait aussi de rien et non ceux qui
étaient venus mêmes goûts banel ici
c'est des députés du nord et gauvain
seuil était venu témoigner à mon procès
en tant que témoin donc c'était vraiment
un grand moment politique la bataille
qui ont engagé les décrocheurs est une
bataille sociale parce que la bataille
écologique a une racine exclusivement
sociales gloire à gaspard et aux
camarades qui mène l'action
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean luc mélenchon qui vient de soutenir
tu es la plus belle chose qui pouvait
arriver à les arrête
ça c'est mon fond d'écran donc c'est moi
et que j'aurais fait l'enfant parce que
quand je suis sortie du tribunal j'ai vu
jean luc mélenchon qui est venu me faire
un câlin pour me féliciter d'avoir fait
mon action est de me dire que j'avais
raison que c'était bien du coup c'était
un grand moment pour moi j'essaie en
fond d'écran puisque c'est un moment
historique de ma vie
[Musique]
le fait que la justice reconnaisse
reconnaisse que mon action est légitime
et correcte et citoyenne et elle doit
être mené
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement satisfaisant pour un
militant finalement je prends des idéaux
et mon objectif c'est de transmettre et
grâce à ce procès j'ai pu transmettre
mes idées grâce à tous les médias qui
m'ont suivi à ce moment là j'ai pu faire
avancer les choses c'est génial c'est
une énorme victoire politique
[Musique]
que là c'est le chat noir cd nom de bar
qui sont assez répandus en france pour
être des bars des repères
d'antifascistes mais vraiment le coeur
des repères anti fasciste
c'est vraiment le coeur battant de
nantes révoltés qui saccagent nantes où
tous les week-ends
ils vendent des goodies il fonde les
autocollants appelant à la haine de
l'état la mort des policiers edit
vendent leurs revues et ils ont sur
leurs réseaux sociaux des relais plus de
200000 personnes qui les suivent
les anti-schiste s'en cache pas du fait
de fréquenter ce bar là mais moi s'il
est ouvert il ya du monde devant si je
passe mieux que j'ai de l'endurance pour
polir parce que là ça va être compliqué
[Musique]
mon probablement suivie puisque ils ont
découvert ou est-ce que j'habitais si je
suis rentré chez moi un jour je suis
arrivée devant ma porte et m'apporter t
on va dire entrouverte légèrement en
fait l'appartement était complètement
retourné sans dessus dessous ce n'était
pas un cambriolage mais c'était un
saccage gratuit je le descends et je
découvre là ma grande la grande porte de
mon entrée taguée avec marquer
clairement dessus antifa similaire qui
est mon nom de famille facho donc
c'était clairement signé
[Musique]
hop on fait tout tout comme elle un faux
pas ok up s est un spot où il ya
vraiment beaucoup de passage avec des
voitures donc ça permet vraiment de
donner de la visibilité à nos affiches
de toute façon elles seront retirées
très rapidement mais là au moins il ya
des passages remarqués devant
la session
[Musique]
on
sait pas trop si c'est pour mon compte
mais on va dire que c'est pour il ya
deux jours à belfort sont pressés et
militants enfin tension
les bulls attentes
clients restent pas longtemps là
on va pas rester longtemps les gars
allez les gars ça qu on me la dernière
bataille a vraiment investi il se ramène
à plusieurs et qu'ensuite il se met face
à nous c'est ça en fait après il appelle
etc il ya plusieurs voitures qui
arrivent et là c'est la merde vraiment
sa main on y va reprendre et pêche
sont deux noms mais c'est toujours le
problème du téléphone c'est à dire que
là ils sont deux mais ensuite c'est du
bouche à oreille il ramène trois
personnes quatre personnes et on se
retrouve sur des collages avec des
voitures de avec quatre ou cinq voitures
qui viennent et ensuite qu'à gaston
militants
donc voilà on est passé il n'y a même
pas dix minutes il n'y a plus aucune
affiche je trouve que c'est vraiment
dommage on a des gens qui se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui on a plus de 5 6
personnes qui sont venues spécialement
pour coller pour créer une dynamique
autour des mandants lille est en fait on
a tous notre travail qui réduit à néant
dix minutes je veux dire à la ja ça n'a
aucun bénéfique et en fait au final on
devrait peut-être même reconnaissant du
fait qu'ils aient simplement racheter
nos affiches et qui nous est pas suivie
frappé insulter
vandaliser
c'est vraiment une soirée qui a été
réduite au néant
notre force de travail a été piétinée
quand on avait interrogé ces jeunes sur
qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont entrés
dans un parti politique au delà des
trajectoires personnelles il ya deux
choses qui sortaient de manière très
forte même trois choses d'abord mezzo
voce contribué au débat d'idées aux
grands débats de société
deuxièmement et c'est plus important
pouvoir être élu troisièmement
faire en sorte de contribuer à désigner
leur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
qui mieux que moi à mon niveau peut
faire avancer la cause des nude contre
les violences sexistes la lutte en
faveur du climat la lutte des inégalités
salariales femmes hommes et c'est vrai
que le schéma qui de dire je constate la
société est injuste je veut adhérer à un
parti politique pour changer les choses
est un schéma qui stien qui concerne
beaucoup de jeunes
[Musique]
il au tabac très bien toi je voulais
voir leur toit pour le planning jusqu'à
thévenot a accepté de débattre avec nous
je dis donc ce sera un des majors avec
tous les ânes ouzou prendre 30 35
personnes dans un bar j'ai fait un
visuel tout un pan de quoi retrouver un
titre genre accrocheur tu vois trois
mots écouter dialoguer les convaincre la
trop forte tac et on est bon bien
parfait mais on peut lancer la pomme
interne à les
coûts hors du coup de choi alors c'est
bien qu'on puisse voir parce que comme
ça on va pouvoir parler un peu de ce
soir prisca elle va arriver le but c'est
que les militants on puisse leur donner
des petits tips sur le terrain en mode
tractage collage comment est-ce qu'on
réagit face à quelqu'un qui par exemple
peut se montrer virulent quelqu'un qui
nous met face à parfois nos propres
contradictions où nos trucs comme ça
sort donné qu'elle a fait beaucoup de
média training toi tu fais l'intro que
tu souhaites je pense que elle aussi ça
va lui tiendra à coeur d'évoquer des
vieux d'évoquer les violences faites aux
femmes etc le harcèlement on verra mais
ça va bien se passer ce soir je pense
que ça va être une belle séquence ça va
nous faire enfin c'est bien les jeunes
vont peuvent savoir qu'ils se retrouvent
et puis après on
on verra
[Musique]
va démarrer par un petit porte à porte
sur ces barres d'immeubles où l'idée
c'est de présenter donc ce petit tract
avec l'essentiel du programme qui est à
l'arrière on choisit réveiller de comres
comme à l'école septième pour qu'il est
parti c'est parti
bonjour ça me prend beaucoup de temps
c'est vrai mais c'est un choix je choisi
de soutenir la candidature de jean-luc
mélenchon et j'ai envie qu'il gagne bas
pour le faire gagner il faut militer il
faut convaincre les langues donc je fais
je vous distribuer le programme de jean
luc mélenchon vous connaissez jean luc
mélenchon là je trouve que le smic 1400
honnête je pense est faisable
on se dit qu'il ya tellement de chômage
que si on partage le temps de travail et
qu'on passe de 32 arrêts du coup
forcément je suis plombier chauffagiste
et si je viens chez vous et le dépanner
pour vous dépanner pour une chaudière
que ça me prend trois heures à partir de
5 heures vous n'allez pas me dire
revenez demain mais du coup on va
travailler là-dessus et c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont voter jean luc mélenchon on
prend compte que les gens s'intéressent
beaucoup plus qu'avant à la chose
politique parce que bon il ya eu les
gilet jaune ya tous les line up
vaccinale qui entrent et qui mobilise
beaucoup les gens ils s'intéressent en
fait à ce qui se passe actuellement il
s'intéresse au débat public est en fait
ils n'aiment pas ce que macro effet
notre sont contents qu'on leur propose
des alternatives et convient on ne vend
maintenant on peut faire autrement et on
va faire autrement
[Musique]
on est très actif sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est là qu'on peut
toucher du monde en plus des porte à
porte c'est bien d'aller discuter avec
les gens c'est mieux c'est plus facile
mais aussi on fait une barre d'immeuble
on va toucher une trentaine de personnes
alors qu'avec une vidéo de jean luc
mélenchon ça peut atteindre des millions
de personnes forcément c'est un enjeu
qui est très important et tous les
candidats l'ont compris et tous les
candidats on recopiait ce que jean luc
mélenchon avait fait dans sa première
campagne en 2017 jean luc pelland fin
effet sa chaîne youtube qui avait
explosé ce qui est sale a beaucoup
propulsant en 2017 et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui tous les hommes
politiques et les femmes politiques sont
sur les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
je disais avant
c'est bon bonjour mesdames je suis
responsable des femmes et exhibant
doriot de france donc ravis de vous
rencontrer je vais essayer de voir s'il
ya des femmes qui veulent rejoindre la
banderole
vous voulez pas aller vers l'avant vol
ça vous intéresse pas alors on est
journaliste a besoin
super
est ce qu est ce que tu veux faire la
photo avec les femmes a été mûri non tu
veux pas tu peux pas ok ça marche pas
tout si marie tu de médéa la photo tu
viens vous venez des rares pancartes ou
pas on a une section qui est
grandissante avec des femmes qui sont de
plus en plus motivés et c'est donc oui
bien sûr moi j'ai absolument pas quoi et
je suis fier même d'être responsable des
femmes avec zemmour de la caméra
grâce à un énorme sourire l'habitat est
assez actif sur les réseaux sociaux avec
les femmes à eghezée moore on a
notamment effectué on de paris qui est
la plus importante mais on essaie
justement de faire des contre-pouvoirs
un peu dans toutes les autres régions
pour montrer qu'on est vraiment répartis
sur toute la france
[Musique]
chez les cher aux banques est on a
vraiment une jeunesse car un rôle
primordial notamment sur la mobilisation
des réseaux sociaux donc aujourd'hui oui
on est acquis pour le voir on organise
des événements donc c'est une preuve de
confiance donc forcément c'est partie de
la jeunesse avant tout
[Applaudissements]
on essaye d'avoir toujours un jeune avec
nous avec une équipe
ouais
mais cheval est là aussi
de chez nous de chez nous ok très bien
nickel
merci
[Musique]
moi ça fait dix ans que je suis là j'ai
collé des affiches de pic depuis je suis
militant j'ai tracté depuis je suis
militant et je continue de le faire
encore aujourd'hui bonjour messieurs
dames un peu de lecture en ce dimanche
vous avez le droit à une belle haie
d'honneur profitez bien
de ça les mêmes profitez-en c'est pas de
chez nous ça
ça lui
mais bon on accepte emmanuel balcon
quand même beaucoup c'est pareil voilà
nous sépare on se respecte ce qui se
fait très régulièrement c'est qu'on
échange nos tracts genre c'est un peu le
bonjour républicain tu vois on n'est pas
d'accord mais moi je prends ton traque
tu prends le mien ça c'est pareil si tu
le fais avec tout le monde donc bon
courage merci merci bien vous aussi
campagne merci aussi au rendez vous le
24 avril absolument
[Musique]
né dans le local du parti communiste est
là comme vous pouvez le voir bas on est
dans notre rôle où il ya tous les tracts
les affiches c'est vraiment le lieu où
tous les communistes peuvent prendre le
matériel et mettre en place leurs
actions pour la campagne
[Musique]
bonjour pour les élections
présidentielles le programme des
communistes pour les jeunes ça vous
intéresse
tenez vous propose notamment un revenu
étudiants hauteur de 850 euros qui peut
aller jusqu'à 1000 euros selon un
système de bourse oui pour faire
ensemble pour faire que tous les
étudiants puissent étudier sans avoir à
salariés à côté souvent ils comprennent
pas forcément pourquoi on leur parle de
politique notre but c'est décidé elle
aussi de leur faire comprendre que ça
peut changer leur vie et que la jeunesse
ça doit être la priorité en fait dans
toutes les élections vous êtes en perte
à sa politique ou pas vous
pas encore regarder les programmes et ou
encore ok
nous serons nous dans ce traquenard
justement détail nos propositions
majeures pour les jeunes pour nous c'est
super important d'attirer l'attention
des jeunes surtout que certains au parti
communiste mais je fais aussi au
mouvement des jeunes communistes de
france est en fait notre rôle c'est pour
utiliser la jeunesse parce que y'a rien
qui terrifie plus un gouvernement de
droite que des jeunes qui sortent dans
la rue qui bloquent leur lycée leur fac
qui se mettent à manifester bonjour pour
les élections présidentielles
bonjour pour les élections
présidentielles le programme des
communistes pour les jeunes bonne
journée
[Musique]
bonjour madame l'élection présidentielle
bonjour madame pour les élections
présidentielles le programme des
communistes vous intéresse bonjour
madame tenez à jour monsieur tous les
élections présidentielles le programme
des communistes et vous intéresse non
merci pas de soucis vous n'êtes pas
d'accord vous votez pas sur quoi a
pas de souci et pourquoi vous voterez
pas pour lui parce que je veux un grand
souvenir du stalinisme dans le temps
parce que moi je suis un vieux et le
communisme il a le temps de mourir puis
les remarquables ouais
pas de soucis alors quand ils sont
vraiment convaincus convaincu très sont
partis nous déteste me déteste
quand on parle aux gens de communisme
pour eux c'est leur évoque l'urss et
c'est
l'histoire du parti communiste en france
c'est la sécurité sociale les congés
payés les grandes grèves les grandes
luttes sociales la résistance le droit
de vote des femmes sas et oussalah parti
communiste en france
bonjour madame aux élections
présidentielles ceux ci bonjour monsieur
pour l'élection présidentielle le
programme des communistes aux intéresse
vous n'êtes pas d'accord ou
bonne journée
[Musique]
ce bonjour rendre aux français leur
fille marine le pen bonjour madame pour
compenser leur pays madame bonjour vous
l'avez déjà
celui ci peut lire avait plus grand
intérêt alors vous appréciez le
programme du rassemblement la salle pour
plutôt punk et 2e comme tout scrutin
promis pour quelqu'un de nouveau pas
vrai c'est vrai qu'elle est donnée dans
les sondages comme à 46% dans la marche
des revenus de 22 semaines en tout cas
si vous nous soutenez déjà dans les
urnes monsieur c'est une grande avancée
je vous en remercie c'est tout à fait
gratuit
l'annexion d'une immense madame vous
savez la mode et des idées et gagné par
le rassemblement national depuis
plusieurs années puisque les sondages
puisque 73% et parfois jusqu'à 80 % des
français en ont assez de la subversion
mille rapport qu'ils subissent tous les
jours
c'est marine le pen la première
présidente de la france à la voile a
très bien très bon dimanche
bon
goûter
les oripeaux de la lutte antiraciste on
les connaît un
bon jour vous faites pour qui
anne hidalgo d'accord les vrais sujets
l'urbanisation de paris où la rue de
rivoli interdite aux voitures
nationaux d'accord dans l'hôpital bon
évidemment
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur pour une société un peu
plus juste et puis surtout on veut
mettre un peu plus d'écologie un peu
plus de vert dans notre société j'ai pas
à vous si ce que vous en pensez je pense
qu'hier que du bien vous voulez un peu
plus de vert
pour la génération future aussi le
présidentielle un candidat écologiste
pour l'avenir de nos enfants et puis
notre santé jusque vous angoisser je
veux pas vous casser le moule oui je
mélange ont un nouveau départ c'est pas
combattants vote mais pas pour lui et
vous madame qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais moi je m'en fous voter ballonnet tu
mangeras 3 voilà mais ça il faut
s'exprimer exprimer votre
c'est déjà très bien je vous laisse j'ai
quatre actes c'est gentillet madar merci
bonne aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous de l'écologie
jusqu'à wiiware pour supporter que c'est
important si vous êtes gêne un peu comme
moi et je pense que pour tous les jeunes
justement on veut améliorer la vie c'est
important pour notre avenir pour moi
tracts et ça me permet aussi d'essayer
de redonner de l'espoir aux personnes
qui pensent que l'écologie
c'est important mais qui n'y croient
plus non non yannick jadot et là il
pourra lui mettre en place de mesures
concrètes et vers un avenir plus juste a
su avant j'aurais yannick jadot voilà m
plus d'écologie
je suis bon jour pour les élections
présidentielles yannick jadot
oui
eric jadot candidat
[Musique]
bonjour ça vaut un trader parisien
bonjour à vous tombez dans carrie jeunes
karryjane oui
du coup c'est tout au fond
c'est un parti qui a comme valeur la
justice sociale un parti progressiste un
parti qui prend en considération la
justice environnementale et qui a des
valeurs sociales très fortes et puis
aussi dans l'ancien temps on a souvent
le parti socialiste et c'est un très
gros party un parti historique et est
encore aujourd'hui ça l'est bonjour
oui il ya des places assisses faudra
juste aller tout au fond c'est ça
l'accord merci au meeting ça fait
plaisir de voir les gens qui viennent
pour écouter hidalgo les sondages certes
c'est des sondages mais la réalité des
urnes c'est pas la réalité des sondages
merci de faire un triomphe à notre temps
visage
[Applaudissements]
je laissais vous croyez toujours à nos
valeurs alors pas trop
moi à l'avenir de la gauche et à
l'avenir de la france
à vous
moi ça me fait plaisir ça me fait
plaisir ne prendre pas j'aimerais avoir
encore plus encore plus de choses encore
plus de meeting elle a très bien parlé
des concise c'était parfait
[Applaudissements]
plus que des militants qu'il y encore
quelques années pouvait adhérer à un
parti et en épouse et l'intégralité du
programme ou du projet ou de la
plateforme on observe une jeunesse qui
va avoir dans la période que nous
connaissons tendance à se mobiliser à
s'impliquer sur des causes alors le
climat ça peut être le bien-être animal
ça peut être se battre contre les
inégalités sociales la précarité
l'engagement il se fait sur la cause et
le vote ensuite il se fait sur le
programme de l'un ou l'une en fonction
peut-être de cette cause
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous avez une génération qui
allait être amenés à gouverner à prendre
des décisions maintenant on est là pour
passer à l'action et c'est évidemment
maintenant votre rôle que de prendre
votre destin en main et que d'être gelée
se faire dans les prochains mois les
futurs députés et peut-être les futurs
ministres de marine le pen bon courage
bonne campagne à tous et on se retrouve
[Applaudissements]
j'espère qu'il aura l'occasion peut-être
d'être élu parce que c'est quand on est
élu qu'à un moment donné on peut changer
agir
et prendre des décisions mais c'est vrai
que le rassemblement national a
historiquement toujours été le parti qui
accorder une chance et une opportunité à
la genèse opportunité de prendre son
destin en main de prendre des décisions
et on a beaucoup de jeunes mères de
jeunes parlementaires et probablement
que tu seras là nos futurs députés aux
moyens
à ce soir c'est la galette
traditionnelle des républicains on l'a
fait un peu tous les ans avec les jeunes
c'est aussi ça la politique la politique
c'est créer des liens c'est créer du
souci oui voilà il faut pas les décevoir
il faut aller à leur rencontre folle et
discuter avec eux et leur montrer que la
famille politique c'est justement pour
les femmes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les anti fasciste tremble et
il était temps les anti fasciste qui
depuis 2012 au moins réunis dans un
groupuscule sèment la terreur dans toute
la ville de nantes et bien aujourd'hui à
le processus de dissolution qui a été
engagée c'est une véritable victoire
c'est extraordinaire
ravi de recevoir parce que pour certains
on a connu il ya longtemps un peu et
puis on t'a vu faire plein de choses et
puis elle fait la campagne et woippy a
été porte parole donc et on est content
et ça prouve aussi qu'on ait un
mouvement où tout le monde peut avancer
tout le monde peut trouver est ce qu'il
a envie de faire dans ce mouvement moi
là où je me sens le plus à l'aise le
plus utile c'est en porte à porte c'est
en tractage c'est là où on a des
échanges des relations et ce débat que
vous pouvez mener c'est le kilomètre
zéro de la communication vous êtes tous
ici le kilomètre zéro de la
communication ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
débattre échanger avec tout le monde
mouche sur les plateaux vous est là on
vous passe le relais il faut qu'on aille
chercher voix parents et quand je dis
voix par voie et ça c'est important pour
la république pour la nation
c'est une photo qui a été prise à la
suite du meeting de lille où j'ai marqué
fiers de participer à cette merveilleuse
aventure et de la reconquête et surtout
vive la france en ce poste a extrêmement
bien marché puisque j'ai eu 3469 laïque
823 retweet et 79 commentaire ça a été
le plus beau moment du meeting de lille
il nous a d'ailleurs il a félicité tous
les militants pour le travail magnifique
il était extrêmement heureux et fier
voilà
[Musique]
je vais réaliser une lessive 100% fait
maison avec des produits écoresponsables
et naturel
aujourd'hui l'écologie c'est vu comme
une mode tant mieux parce que du coup ça
a des effets positifs mais voilà faut
que ça est quand même au delà de ça il
faut que ce soit quelque chose qui soit
concret en fait pour pour tout le monde
et que ce soit vraiment un objectif à
atteindre la doré dur c'est son
empreinte carbone parce que si
aujourd'hui on n'essaie pas de faire un
effort on le paiera plus tard
adrien voilà bravo à toi l'action
militante elle repose aussi beaucoup sur
ses jeunes qui s'engagent c'est
essentiel groupe la même manière que les
générations qui nous ont précédés ont vu
lui même évolué et nous on les a vus
arriver comme gaspard l'audi quoi
d'abord par curiosité qui aujourd'hui
être des piliers de l'organisation
militante
[Musique]
peut-être c'est vraiment épaisse en fait
à l'épée si la force
maintenant il ya un vrai parti qui
s'occupe du monde du travail et qui a
pour volonté d'aller chercher les gens
là qui étaient trompés par le front
national
et nous on a pour but de leur parler à
ces gens là de leur dire mais ne trompe
pas de combat
en tant que jeunes souvent les camarades
du parti de disques là relève c'est nous
et on est on est quand même des
militants internationalistes on mène
toujours des luttes pour la justice et
la paix dans le monde et bien sûr que
l'idée c'est d'avoir une france
communiste à la fin mais pas qu'une
france un monde communiste
[Musique]
bon ça va s'amuser
c'est son cousin luigi
22 ans
assise à côté voilà longtemps que les
services je me vois un peu en oeuvre à
l'époque où j'étais obligé de bosser
pour payer mes études du coup ça me
permet aussi de comprendre lui d'être un
peu mieux la vie qui est la sienne et en
quoi la politique tout simplement pu
essayer des jus quoi que ce soit moins
galère
on l'envi le talent les désirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même si d'algos ne parvient pas à
devenir président de la république ce
combat je le mènerai avis en l'amène à
vie j'ai décidé de m'engager
personnellement pour le parti salissez
pour les valeurs du parti socialiste avi
je n'essayerai le plus de faire émerger
les valeurs là ces valeurs du
social-démocrate ses valeurs a une
sensibilité sociale forte et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai rejoint le
parti socialiste donc demain si
d'allemands ne venait à part emporté
l'animation présidentielle sait pas ce
qui va faire que j'arrête mon combat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]